et votre actualité c'est un site
gamasutra bairro co.com alors vous
partager un peu de votre savoir au sujet
de 35 position et alors je vais faire un
tour évidemment je suis très
professionnel il ya trois packs de
tutoriels alors il ya le parc septième
ciel le pack excitation et le pacte
tentation est ce que ça correspond à
trois niveaux de moi je dois dire savoir
c'est que 35 position oui c'est de
l'expérience sur trente cinq années à
croquer donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
positions qui est on connaisse la
missionnaire la levrette la chandelle il
ya beaucoup d'émotions comme ça mais il
ya beaucoup d'autres positions que
j'espère monter dans ma vie par exemple
il ya des positions que les personnes ne
connaissent pas mais où on peut donner
du plaisir on des positions tellement
compliqué mais en même temps relax et
pour les gens qui sont fétichiste tu as
la possibilité d'avoir un pénétration
lécher les pieds au même temps de faire
lécher les pieds au même temps faire un
petit peu de cirque magie non non c'est
ainsi que par exemple écouter ma femme
qui nous écoutent
elle fait qu'une position avec moi
depuis beaucoup d'années
pourquoi parce qu'elle est l'impact déjà
quand j'ai commencé je fais et 15
positions et le mag a remis des comptes
ce que tu arrêtes et tu me fais rire
pour de vrai parce que elle avait un peu
noël avait un peu du mal à me dire à
rocco siffredi mais pourquoi tu fais que
c'est pour cela je vais amener un peu la
façon de travailler à la maison
elle appuie six mois avant de milliers
de la vérité après on se relaxe et ma
femme elle jouit avec une solution que
c'est une classe estime que les
missionnaires
mais c'est fait avec au moins dix
différence de deux angles on le prend de
l'âge et on le précédent
ça y est on bosse on bouge et on bouge
et oui tu peux avoir beaucoup d'organes
je vis comme ça mais si vous laissez
vous aller courir c'est tout est une
question d'essayer de si les mecs c'est
ça les petites questions d'ordre
cinématographique presque avec de grands
comédiens c'est que je trouvais que le
c'était vous avez quand même des moyens
maintenant vous êtes une grande star etc
j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu cheap vos
vidéos
c'est à dire que le saumon on a
l'impression qu'on est dans une salle de
bain vous avez un peu de rouge s'est
passé en termes de ttt petite réponse
la réalité c'est pas moi que j'ai les
produits oui je les données simplement
mon image et mon expérience
mais avant d'entrer dans les détails les
plus chaudes
est-ce que ce cas va se trompe en parler
avec les copains en coulisses est-ce que
c'est du second degré parce que quand
vous êtes en train de faire le poirier
du soleil avec faute petit sip rouge et
vos lunettes de soleil et vous fait ce
genre de visages autodérision sa salle
le poirier indien faut être bien et son
fils mais il est le ps que je parce que
je sais que vous avez beaucoup d'humour
on est d'accord que c'est du second
degré personne ne fait l'amour en slip
rouge avec des lunettes de soleil ou
alors peut-être comment on va lui
suffisait cette question alors la
bizarre votre vidéo c'est un peu
surréaliste
non mais d'abord qu'est léger mais s'est
fait beaucoup il n'y a pas que des
lunettes de soleil non via aussi un
problème à un moment donné si je peux me
permettre c'est vrai vous parlez du kama
sutra
ces deux là je suis pas le producteur
on va avancer on en revient à l'ailé
quel est le but
mais si tel est le but vous pourquoi
vous faites ça ok je hockey sincèrement
sincèrement ça l'argent surtout mon bien
bien payé moi mais la réalité mais j'ai
dit quand même je vous dit où les
positions les choses donc qu'ils avaient
pas vraiment beaucoup de notation de ça
qu'il faut faire mais en même temps ils
ont dit ça va être un test on sait pas
ce match ça marche pas donc ils ont pas
mis une grande fortune là dessous
aujourd'hui la pornographie sur internet
il ya plus de grands badge est n importe
quelle direction à skis et beaucoup de
ces toutous gratuit donc malheureusement
c'est comme ça